what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so I am on retconning my own
video series with planet hook finished I
had intended to jump directly into World
War Hulk um and the first video of world
war hulk will be like so with planet
hulk finished so so you know kind of
bear with me on that one but I've long
since been trying to find the origin
story of Lyra the incredible Hawks
daughter because you guys love
Incredible Hulk style you guys go ham
over the Incredible Hulk stuff I don't
know what it is supposed to call me
because I want to know why do you guys
love incredible whole content so much
I'm kind of curious but I finally found
it I was finally able to locate it and
so because of this I want to cover this
story now the story of Lyra is actually
really really interesting because it
involves what are basically called the
gender Wars now the great thing about
this as you know this this particular
story as it's effectively written by
Jeff Parker is that it focuses largely
on this idea of an alternate future now
in Marvel Comics we have all kinds of
alternate realities and I believe this
one is referred to as Earth 971 but for
those of you guys who are new to Marvel
Comics this of course was before Secret
Wars so alternate universes receive
numerical designations now all this
really originated with the Captain
Britain Matt Jim Jasper story where the
main Marvel continuity was just referred
to as earth-616 it was a random
numerical designation
there was really no rhyme or reason
because of that model just began to
arbitrarily assign numbers so there's
really no basis behind how those numbers
are assigned they just get numbers it's
just like Earth 1610 is the ultimate
universe 1610 does not stand for
anything that doesn't mean anything in
particular it's just 1610 DC is a lot
easier to understand because they take a
more linear approach you have like earth
1 earth 2 or 3 or 4 so on and so forth
then you have like earth s4 Shazam back
during the pre-crisis on Infinite Earths
era I think it may be even post-crisis
but the idea here is that this is an
earth 970 or 971 and what we're told
or at least how we're told this story is
actually fluctuating between the past
and the
and it works pretty well we're basically
given the Incredible Hulk as he's going
against you know the US Army now this is
not wildly significant with the
Incredible Hulk it really just shows us
how the Hulk lives his life that he's
constantly on the move what is important
here is a character named Thundra now
thunder is has been around since like
1972 she was a Roy Thomas creation and
she was really designed to bolster the
roster of the Incredible Hulk stole a
line of stories because the Incredible
Hulk always suffered from the Superman
complex if the Incredible Hulk gets
stronger the angrier he gets and if he
continues to get angry or whenever he
goes against a foe that he cannot
initially beat well then eventually is
it his strength will get to the point
where he can beat that foe because his
strength is limitless so how do you
write a story less compelling with a
character like that well Peter David did
it by focusing largely on Bruce banners
father the fact that his father was
abusive and we've covered this before
but the idea that you know the abuse of
experiences that Bruce Banner had were
the reason why the incredible whole
persona emerged in the first place
because it's basically the physical
manifestation of all of Bruce Bruce
banners anger almost said Bruce Wayne
there's a physical manifestation of all
of Bruce banners anger and resentment
towards the world but thunder was
designed to be this feminist element or
really tie into young girls now this was
a huge thing back in the early 1970s I
mean you know we were coming out and we
were really in you know a good portion
of the civil rights movement and the
civil rights movement contrary to what a
lot of people think was not really so
much a african-american movement so much
as it was a equality movement I mean
there a lot of the emphasis is put on
African Americans and there was a lot of
action with regards to African Americans
but you know if you go I can look at the
or any of the old speeches of Martin
Luther King if you go back and look at
any of the old speeches of a lot of the
prominent civil rights movement leaders
who weren't necessarily those that
advocated violence to those who held
strict adherence to African American
values a lot of the statements that were
made pertained to everybody and if you
go back and watch any of the old footage
with regards to civil rights you'll see
a multicultural group of people as
opposed to just African Americans but
the goal of Marvel at the time was to
tap into this movement that's one of the
reasons why we got shang-chi that's why
we got Luke AIDS that's why we got Iron
Fist day near and it was tapping into
all these different elements of
multiculturalism this really came to a
head in 1975 with Chris Claremont's
giant-size x-men when it was a new
multicultural roster of x-men from
people who hail
from different locations around the
world Thundra was designed to be one of
you know a series of characters going
all the way back to carol danvers really
that served the purpose of trying to
bring young girls into comic books but
also showing diversity in the sense that
Thundra was every ounce as strong and
capable as Ben Graham and The Incredible
Hulk to a degree and so it was like this
Wonder Woman s sort of character who
could hold her own against some of the
strongest men in Marvel Comics now this
struck a chord with some readers because
they hated the idea of just constantly
having feminism thrown in their face but
it also struck a chord with some readers
who loved the idea of seeing more
prominent female characters that really
depended on the viewpoints of those
individuals their life experiences and
what it was that they were looking for
in comic books but the overall goal of
this particular story more or less
highlights the case that Thundra is
using a bit of deception and this is
kind of the crazy thing because this
story is given to us largely in a
third-person monologue that is to say
someone who is effectively telling us
everything that's going on and what we
learn at least you know by way of Jeff
Parker going through and retconning
things is he's essentially telling us
that all the times a thunder had gone
into the past and fought the various
heroes it was for a couple purposes now
we knew even going all the way back to
her first appearance we knew that
thunder was a time traveler like we knew
that she hailed from the future that
wasn't something new this isn't
something newly created the motivation
behind it is the reason why it is a huge
deal when she first popped up it was the
simple argument women are better than
men and just as capable as men and so
Thunder is going to prove that by
fighting some of the strongest men in
existence what we actually learn here is
that in the world that she hails from
that throughout their own experiences
their own actions their own
investigations and and their own efforts
and so on that men continue to improve
in terms of intelligence you know that
knowledge of science mathematics
athleticism so on and so forth the
problem with this was that women were
also keeping up as well but it created a
rift between the two of them that men
weren't able to accept women being equal
and women couldn't accept being on the
same foot as men instead each group
began to basically go about their own
individual arguments and for women
especially it was the idea that if we
are equal than men then we can
better than them and so what this did is
it effectively led to the gender wars in
the sense that you had men who were now
being educated separate from women you
had women who were now engaging in
exercise activities and political
politics that were outside or at least
beyond the scope of the ability for men
to affect and so because of this it
started to create this massive rift and
it was a sort of separation between the
genders now as time progressed because
men were trying to keep up with women
and trying to keep themselves ahead of
the curve a lot of men ended up
irradiating themselves now we're not
explicitly told by Jeff Parker whether
or not this ties into the hope but it
seems like it does it seems like a lot
of men in this society had looked at the
Incredible Hulk as literally limitless
in terms of strength and aspired to be
equal to that and so because of that
they basically irradiated themselves and
in doing so made themselves infertile
meaning that there were no more new
children being born following this war
that had taken place around 20 years
prior to that and so what we learn is
that with Thundra coming back to the
modern day and going against the
Incredible Hulk this is done because of
the fact that the Hulk is largely
considered to have been the strongest
being that ever lived because again his
strength was limitless there was no
limit to how strong he could get and so
while Thunderer fights against him and
while he is able to hold his own she
essentially says that hey look you know
once once the conflict comes to an end
once once Hulk out proves just how
capable he is you know she says hey look
you know I'm not here to really harm you
I'm here because I need to find someone
who's equal to me I basically need to
find a man I need to find a man that's
on par with me that can allow the human
race to continue and so what she does is
she actually embraces the Incredible
Hulk and she kisses him now of course we
know the kissing does not I guess it
does kind of lead to procreation but in
the in the context of simply just
kissing someone kissing doesn't produce
children instead what we learn is that
when Thunder had kissed the Incredible
Hulk the she had actually taken cells
from the inside of his cheek she had
traveled back to her home dimension and
they had effectively used these cells to
impregnate her to basically use you know
vitro fertilization in order to make her
pregnant the first woman to actually
become pregnant in about 20 years
and so following this what had happened
was she'd given birth to a daughter and
because Thunderer realized that she was
basically growing all the time would
come when she would no longer be able to
remain the leader of these
women in this you know new United States
of America that was now the United
sisterhood Republic I think it was
because of the fact that they were
waging a war against men that someone
would have to take up her mantle someone
would have to be equal to her and
strength and be able to continue her
efforts and so the daughter that she
gave birth to was essentially Lyra and
Lyra is a combination of the strength
that Thunder has as well as the
Incredible Hulk
which meant that she was now capable of
being just as strong as her mother if
not a little bit stronger carry on the
efforts of this war and eventually lead
toward to destroy the entirety of men on
on the face of the planet earth but with
that being said guys this is kind of a
weird story there's a gender war story
um that's really all it is but if you
guys are new here to comics explained
and you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
rock Court if you guys enjoy this video
let me know down in the comments section
and yeah now we'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]